une tendance à la baisse pour autant
l'épidémie de bronchiolite est toujours
en cours le dernier point
épidémiologique de la rs fait état de
105 1 en une semaine contre 145
précédemment un chiffre en diminution
mais toujours au dessus des valeurs
saisonnières et qui appelle à la
prudence des parents quand ils voient
sans enfant qui tousse tousse beaucoup
avec des difficultés respiratoires avec
associés à des sifflements et un enfant
surtout qu'ils ne mangent plus beaucoup
ne bois plus beaucoup
dors beaucoup aussi est fatigué à ce
moment là peut pleurer aussi parce qu'il
varie peu souffrir aussi à ce moment là
il va consulter rapidement leur médecin
des cas peuvent être plus ou moins
graves
pour autant ce médecin recommande
d'appliquer le principe de précaution
pour un nouveau né un enfant il ne faut
jamais attendre
quel que soit l'état des enfants il faut
toujours là mais le plus tôt possible
vers le médecin et avoir des formes plus
ou moins grave ça ça dépend ça dépend de
tes capacités pulmonaires du nourrisson
en fait à noter également une légère
amélioration au niveau des urgences
pédiatriques où seule une admission sur
quatre a nécessité une hospitalisation
contre une sur deux les semaines
précédentes